Do you ever look down at your sleeping pet
and think how similar you guys are?
Your dog might me as hyped as you are about an upcoming event
and your cat may be rolling your eyes with you at something annoying.
There is a reason why the terms ''cat people''
and ''dog people'' exist.
Your preference for felines or canines reflects inherent
personality traits corresponding to your favorite animal.
A study in the University of Texas assessed a large group
of people on 5 main personality traits commonly known
as the ''Big Five'' - the parameters often used
by psychologists.
1: Contientiousness
Your level of contientiousness indicates your  inclination
towards diligence and
organization when carrying out a task.
Dog people were rated to be 11% more
contientious than cat people because their sense of duty
and obedience makes them more likely to follow rules.
This is not to say that cat people aren't willful;
but they tend to question situations, motives and orders
as an act of self preservation.
2: Agreeableness
Your level of agreeableness shows how quickly and to what degree
you trust others. Dog people are high in this attribute
and are generous to everyone they meet, genuinely sympathetic
to others needs and sometimes even gullible to a fault.
Cat people, on the other hand,
have a reputation for being standoffish because of their
low level of agreeableness. They're often
weary with strangers, taking time to gauge
an individual and slowly warming up to them.
3: Neuroticism
Your level of neuroticism refers to how
well you can manage your emotions. Cat people are
calculated to be 12% more neurotic
than dog people because they possess a sensitivity that makes them
more prone to worrying and overthinking.
Since their spectrum of thought
is much wider than that of dog people
they also spot more problems to stress over, real
or imagined. Dog people are more easy going
and tend to be less anxious overall.
4: Openness
Your level of openness indicates your reception to new things,
readiness to explore, imaginitive vividness
and intellectual curiosity. Cat people
are said to me more open as they have a natural
curiosity to discover and experiment more, and hold
unconventional beliefs. They have
an independence that reflects that of their
pet allowing them to be sensitive and open minded to creative
and intellectual pursues.
Some interesting research shows that cat people
are actually more likely to be atheists than dog people.
Dog owners tend to stick to safer, calculated choices
in unfamiliar situations and are
more likely to believe authority figures without question.
Their values are also more traditional and conservative.
5: Extraversion
Similar to agreeableness, extraversion is a measure of sociablity
Your level of extraversion indicates where you derive your
energy from. Dog people are
rated to be 15% more extroverted,
taking the initiative in social situations
while cat people tend to shy away from crowds.
Thus, cat people are more likely to live alone,
particulary in apartments as they're more introverted.
The experimenter conducting this study, Sam Gosling,
said: ''There's a widely held cultural belief that
the pet species - dog or cat -
with which a person has the strongest affinity
says something about the individual's personality.''
And this research suggests that there are significant differences
on major personality traits between
dog people and cat people.
The next time you settle down for a movie with your cat
or go for a drive with your dog, you'll know
the reason you get along so famously isn't coincidence
but a real likeliness in character.
Do you have any pets? If so,
do you believe your personality reflects that of your pet's?
Feel free to share in the comments below!
If you enjoyed this video, be sure to check out our
website and other social media as well as our new Patreon account.
Thanks for watching!